[Musique]
si on se parlait un peu d'audio
aujourd'hui ça va les grandes patate
aujourd'hui la grande pêche aujourd'hui
c'est sneijder qui m'a demandé de vous
parler donnent leurs produits c'est
laisser x400 bt ce sont des écouteurs
trou wireless ce sont des ingrats intra
intéressant un très intéressant c'est
dur à dire mais ça se dit quand même et
ses écouteurs les est ici alors je les
écoute et les miens oreilles j'écoutais
plein plein plein plein plein de musique
avec et maintenant il est l'heure vous
donner mon retour vous dire ce que je
pense justement de ces nouveaux intra de
senna isr est ce qu elles sont
intéressantes pas comment il se
positionne dans la gamme
et puis au final est-ce qu'il faut les
acheter quel style de musique sera plus
préconisé d'écouté avec enfin voila cela
un tour complet de la question je vous
dis tout mais juste avant et je vais
vous les montrer ce qu'ils sont cachés
ou tous tombés il faut cacher là dedans
dans cette petite boîte on va certes un
rapide tour du propriétaire pour voir ce
qui est à l'intérieur de cette boîte
dans lesquelles sont cachés c'est un
coûtera dans les peuples ils sont
normalement positionner ici vous en
douterez comme j'ai écouté j'ai déjà
sorti vous avez des guides de garantie
des informations on va retrouver ici à
l'intérieur un petit câble pour venir
leurs charges et de l'usb vert de l'usb
c'est parce que oui si on vient soit
chargée en usb c'est directement à
l'arrière tout pratique et vous avez
surtout des embouts de différentes
tailles en fonction de la taille de
votre oreille xs small medium large pour
vraiment me retrouvais la taille qui
vous correspond donc à de quoi faire et
c'est extrêmement important de bien
choisir la taille de saison bout pour ça
rentre bien dans vos oreilles sans quoi
vous restaurer rapidement déchanté pour
les mettre c'est très simple il suffit
de les prendre
voyez vous les mettez comme ça dans
votre oreille voulait positionner et
après hop un petit quart de tour voulait
tourner et il vient de se positionner
très naturellement mais si par contre
vous avez pas perdre et hop je les pose
comme ça je tourne comme ça donc ça
devienne vraiment ce qu'elle est au fond
si vous n'avez pas choisi les bonnes
tailles d'embouts et bien vous allez pas
avoir réellement de confort alors ici
vous avez une réduction de bruit pas si
parce que oui ça vient vous boucher les
oreilles ce sont des êtres à vos intra
sont posés dans cette boîte dans cette
petite boîte elle est plutôt sympa le
confort je vous en parlais dans quelques
instants
mais le format est dans l'ensemble
plutôt agréable maintenant il ya un truc
que je vais venir reprochés eh bien
voyez c'est vraiment le
la taille de cette boîte si vous mettez
dans une poche de veste dans un sac à
main ils prendront leur place et ira
bien si par contre comme moi vous les
mettez dans un jean
mais voyez vous avez une espèce de
grosse heure qui vient se détacher pour
ça c'est pas hyper adapté c'est pas
hyper pratique parce que la boîte quand
même
elle n'est pas tout petit c'est du point
de détail me direz vous mais ça va
dépendre évidemment de vous et comment
est ce que vous les utiliser ou est ce
que vous pensez les rangées parlons
maintenant du confort comme je vous le
disais ici on est sur des intras dire
c'est les écouteurs qui vont venir
rentrer dans vos oreilles je prends je
le positionne hop je le tourne il faut
vraiment aimer ce type de confort et ce
type d'écouteurs personnellement j'aime
bien ça revient bien se positionner
alors une fête plus essayer les choisit
c'est vraiment la bonne taille qui vous
correspondra production vraiment
vraiment bien posséder faut pas hésiter
à bien le pousser au fond au maximum
pour vraiment profiter d'un son avec un
peu plus de rondeur c'est plus important
personnellement le confort je trouve
bien je trouve plutôt bien en tenue
bouge pas on pouvait aller pogoter
tranquillement ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose à venir essayer pour se rendre
compte si vous aimez cette typologie de
produits ou pas d'ailleurs dites le moi
en bas en commentaire d'un point de vue
purement matérielle vous allez trouver
la même chose que je veux dans lé
momentum proulx wireless 2 au niveau des
transducteurs vous avez des
transducteurs dynamiques de 7 mm qui est
très sympa c'est clichy sur le côté
c'est un bouton alors vous avez
différents type d'appui qui sont
personnalisables depuis l'application
sage et vous le montrer dans quelques
instants
mais surtout qu'est ce qu'on attend de
ces écouteurs qu'être on attend de ces
intra et bien c'est d'abord une bonne
qualité sonore et c'est ça qui est
justement intéressant alors voyons voir
qu'est ce que donnent ces écouteurs au
niveau de la qualité qu'est ce que
donnent ces cx400 bt trou wireless et
bien croyez le ou non la qualité plutôt
pas mal attention attention d au moins
au style de musique que vous allez
écouter
je vous explique pourquoi parce qu'ici
vous avez un son qui est très doux vous
avez vraiment une signature sonore c'est
dérisoire je ne sais pas si vous avez
déjà eu d'écoutés ou utiliser des
écouteurs sneijder d'ailleurs dites le
moi en bas en commentaire vous avez
vraiment une signature sonore c'est
extrêmement tous et soyeux comme une
petite caresse au niveau des médiums et
des aigus c'est de prendre un peu ses
images parce que c'est vraiment un sac
sainte et pensé par contre ici vous
n'allez pas développé beaucoup de grave
et beaucoup de basse il faut le savoir
et même en les positionnant au maximum
dans votre oreille en les tournant bien
vous n'avez pas avoir un son très grave
vous avez un équaliseur et je vous le
détail dans quelques instants dans votre
application pour venir
du lait corrigée vraiment en fonction de
ce que vous aimez entendre mais malgré
tout vous n'avez pas fabriquer le son
qui ne se fabrique pas et ici il est
gravé les bacilles pas en avoir beaucoup
donc si vous êtes passionné de dr dre
que vous voulez beaucoup de hip hop qui
cartonne avec beaucoup de grâce que vous
écoutez de la musique électro vous
voulez vraiment que ça ronronne
je ne pense pas que ces écouteurs sont
faits pour vous si maintenant vous
voulez profiter d'une qualité claire de
son médium médiums aigus et des aigus si
vous écouter du jazz si vous voulez
écouter du rnb si vous vous écoutez de
la musique classique est bien là dessus
faisant drame une très très bonne
expérience
moi j'ai beaucoup plus aimé écouter au
mieux bande vidéo carreau de la callas
plutôt que d'alcool de kavinsky je
trouvais que ces écouteurs s'y prêtait
vraiment bien alors à côté de sa cabine
ski j'ai toujours bien aimé mais il ya
un moment où on veut que sa couronne et
ça ronronne pas énormément
j'ai aussi apprécié et écouté radiohead
creep qui marche bien mais une fois de
plus il nous manque un petit quelque
chose derrière on a une vraie sensation
de spatialisation de crise de couteau un
autre bon de ce point de vue là ça fera
taf
un des gros point positif c'est
l'application et l'application je les
cache et juste ici elle s'appelle smart
control et smart control c'est pas mal
notamment pour toutes les fonctions
d'égaliseur je vais avoir deux
possibilités soit n'égalise heures
visuel pouvoir venir module est monté
mais médium poussé vers mais aiguë les
diminuer ou alors monté mais grave vous
comprendrez médiums aigus graves et
j'aime vraiment le régler comme je veux
donc là y'a un côté qui est vrai visuel
et le toucher c'est très sympa mais moi
ce que je préférais je suis un peu old
school comme garçons c'est vraiment
avoir mes bandes de fréquences alors en
fait je vois qu'ici j'ai uniquement
trois bandes de fréquences à son écrit
ici grave médiums aigus suis donc avoir
une pente qui est quand même très large
pour me régler des bandes de fréquence
est pas quelque chose qui est très très
très très pointu mais dans l'ensemble ça
fera date on va pas avoir la meilleure
expérience avec les co leaders neutre
moi j'ai créé mon prêt set j'ai créé mon
gros seins ou je vais venir gonfler un
peu mais grave ici vous le voyez j'ai
creusé très rarement des médiums là j'ai
fait choix de laisser mes mais aiguë à 0
mais je peux venir les monter un petit
peu si je le souhaite je veux que déjà
le sont au niveau des aigus et médiums
aigus et très précis très doux et très
fin et conviendra parfaitement bien
comme ça alors voyez ce qui est vraiment
bien établi qu'ils pouvaient venir
personnalisé créé un nouvel équaliseur
je crée un nouveau prêt set je veux
donner le nom
je veux par exemple grehan up grrrr 2 je
fais ok et l'a ensuite
et là je peux venir moduler le maître
comme je veux casser n'est grave ou pas
monter les médiums monter les aigus je
sauvegarde et ensuite je retrouve dans
mes paramètres voyez j'ai mon gré de
montbrehain je fais comme je veux je
peux les renommer je peux les supprimer
ça c'est super donc vous pouvez voir
autant de paramètres que vous vous leur
en fonction des différents styles
musicaux que vous écoutez alors ses
premiers pas qui est vraiment très très
positif le deuxième point on va
retrouver au niveau de la
personnalisation de ses boutons et ça
c'est vraiment des très très très gros
point fort de cette application c'est à
dire je veux vraiment revenir
personnalisés gauche droite je vends une
fonction différente
l'aja puis une fois à gauche ça va être
pleine pause j'appuie une fois à droite
c'est mon assistant vocal que j'écoute
de la musique ou pas d'ailleurs deux
fois morceau précédent à gauche deux
fois à morceau suivant la droite 3 tap
j'ai pas mis de fonction je peux venir a
ajouté une fonction si je le souhaite je
suis sur mon petit crayon et pour nos
trois tables boyer gk appuyé ici et je
peux venir ajouté lecture poste ont
assurément ce précédent assistant vocal
faut vraiment venir paramétrer comme je
le souhaite je sois vraiment extrêmement
pratique lorsque cela s'appuyer et bien
à gauche le baisser le volume
à droite je vais l'augmenter et ensuite
ans que j'ai un appel g puis une fois à
gauche
j'accepte et je termine je puis une fois
à droite except internet j'ai fait
exactement la même chose rejeté un appel
appuyé deux fois vraiment lire
personnalisés comme je veux faire comme
je veux et ça c'est vraiment très très
pratique ça c'est un truc que j'aime
bien mais vous en rendrez pas content
comme ça parce que vous les avez pas à
vos oreilles c'est que vous avez
vraiment une motivation qui est
extrêmement douce c'est vachement sympa
à ce que tu es tactile vous dépassez
comme ça vous vous en rendrez pas con
parce qu'il faut vraiment aller tester
pour pouvoir vous rendre compte
effectivement de cette modulation de
fréquence qui est très très douce et
c'est vraiment ce que j'aime bien c'est
vraiment dans la couleur sénat santé
pensez un peu à ce que j'ai pu
reconnaître quand j'étais assistant en
studio il ya très très très très très
longtemps et que on avait effectivement
je sois pas vous dire c sté du manley où
je sais plus on avait vraiment cette
sensation en fait de douceur lorsque
vous allez venir moduler votre
équaliseur et c'est vraiment tout cas ce
que je ressens lorsque je vais le module
est ici votre application est disponible
sur ios mais également sur android vous
allez bien évidemment à voir google
assistants et série puisqu'on est sûre
retrouvailles en laisse on va se
connecter en bluetooth et du bluetooth
5.1 avec les codecs à csbc et a pété x
sénat vous donne 20 heures d'autonomie
au global cette heure avec vos écouteurs
avec une seule recharge plus très
heures grâce au boîtier de recharge pour
venir vous les recharger alors peut-être
un petit peu moins de 20 heures mais on
est en tout cas dans cette idée là les
garder comme ça vous aurez déjà pendant
sept heures de suite il faut avoir envie
le confort est là c'est agréable mais
malgré tout des fois on est content de
pouvoir les retirer pour pouvoir parler
à des gens des vrais il vous faudra une
heure et demie pour la charge complète
et en dix minutes de recharge
vous êtes parti pour une heure d'écouté
si on veut trouver des points négatifs
je dirais que le premier set fait de ne
pas avoir de réduction de bruit active
ça vous le trouverez sur les momentum
trouvaille or less 2 qui coûte 299 euros
ici faut savoir qu'on est quand même à
199 euros 100 euros de moins
on a une réduction de bruit pas si parce
que ça vient vous boucher les oreilles
et ça débouche quand même plutôt bien
mais pas de réduction brute actifs à ses
premiers points le deuxième point c'est
qu'ils ne sont absolument pas optimisé
pour le sport parce que pas donné
résistant à la transpiration et aux
éclaboussures pour moi c'est vraiment d
un tract vous allez pouvoir utiliser
pour écouter de la musique lorsque temps
déplacements transports en commun dans
un bureau pour une petite pause le soir
dans deux clips mais c'est pas forcément
cela qu'on va bien choisir pour aller
courir en salle ou en extérieur ou chez
vous sur un troisième point un peu
négatif c'est cette taille là je trouve
un petit peu grande pour mettre dans une
poche mais une fois de plus dans un sac
à main dans une sacoche dans un sac
banane dans un cartable dans ce cas sans
aucun problème pour conclure moi j'aime
bien les c'est gestion du mal avec ses
références sont compliquées avec les
cx400 bluetooth bt trou ailleurs l'ex de
senna isr c'est comme le nom c'est
neither j'ai une marque que je connais
depuis très longtemps parce que quand je
bossais je vous dis justement j'étais
assistant studio fait une époque où même
après quand je travaillais dans le sauve
un peu importe on s'en fiche
c'est d'ailleurs c'est une marque qui
ont retrouvé beaucoup partout pour les
micros et pour différents différents
produits j'ai jamais réussi à écrire
c'est neither et à chaque fois que je
travaille pour préparer les vidéos sur
ces 10 heures et bien je peux vous
assurer que je mets toujours à temps
c'est quoi il est où le vit il ya
combien de haine c'est un peu la galère
bah ouais c'est comme ça en tout cas pas
ce produit se trouve intéressant 199
euros ça fonctionnera plutôt pas trop
mal positionné le son est bien une fois
de plus pour les fréquences
guillaume mais jamais dû aiguë on va me
manque un petit peu de grave et ça il
faut vraiment le savoir lorsque vous
allez venir le choisir c'est un produit
qui coule notamment au niveau de
l'application qu'on utilise très très
facilement pour venir à passer un coup
de fil lecture/pause avoir son assistant
bon produit qui est bien qui est dans
l'air du temps
bonne qualité audio si les sénateurs
j'aime bien ce côté son qui est très
très doux fin je vous ai toutes tailles
dans la vidéo personnellement je trouve
vraiment cool si vous intéresse vous
aviez bien évidemment un lien en bas
dans la description si vous voulez la
réduction bref si vous avez d'autres
produits chez sennheiser qui font très
très bien la faire mais si vous voulez
des écouteurs de bonne qualité avec un
son qui est très précis et très agréable
au niveau des médiums aigus et ben je
pense que là vous avez vraiment pas mal
moi personnellement j'ai bien aimé les
écouter je vais d'aimer les tester
pendant quelques temps et s'ils
correspondent à vos attentes musicales
et bien je peux vous les recommandés a
vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
maintenant vous en bas en commentaire
quant à nous on se retrouve très vite
pour continuer à parler de teck parce
qu'on parle de plein de choses plein de
trucs d'ailleurs dit moi sur les sujets
qui vous intéressent
ce sujet vous voudriez qu'on aborde
qu'on n'a pas encore abordé sur la
chaîne câblée marqué en bas en
commentaire des gros bisous beaucoup
d'amour a très vite
[Musique]
il
on
m
[Musique]